okay next game will assess snow kit on
Grand Master here from from Turkey lot
of Turkish Ronan's here second term in
Rome care go for queens in yen I BTW to
the sum I think rambles
yeah this transposed to a well-known top
of position here in the Queen's Indian
but black has positioned his bishop on a
form and this way blocking the porn one
of ya one main idea for wide is to not
move this knight on f3 try to remove the
bishop here and then then the night for
instance some idea like Bishop f1 or h3
then 92 and then coming up with them
with e4 later Black's ideas to stay
flexible here yeah it's it's coming up
just as promised my ideas to play once
the night moves here d 5v5 moves like
this undermining the Ponzi and maybe
fight for the white squares ok so
attacking d6 can cover this
ok now sit down somewhere no just
retreat immediately
okay interesting interesting position
now d5 maybe d5 then e 594 yeah this is
an interesting now type of position with
the bishop being transferred from be 72
e for the 2h7 no idea maybe why it is
still better with the with the two
bishops and the the space advantage but
black has got some ideas as well it's
not dumb not a one-way street I think
yeah of course I need to be cautious
that he doesn't get some some attack
going okay i'm not sure before than a
form i need to i think i want to want
some some concrete counter play here
yeah but I can just just drop this back
here it takes now this is some no big
deal at all okay what now salsa
what what about the move like who in a
sound the idea of taking on b3
getting them getting troops here if it
takes before 10 p-3 a between a one of
course this was also a possibility now I
want to enter with the Queen attacking
b3 is just ignoring it interesting yes I
I understand basically understand age
five and then clean g for something wet
term not sure it is so dangerous
I want to threaten something as well
just once in a while okay okay three
maybe getting getting everything into
play here I Scott Luke I have one not
really to be honest I didn't fully
calculate what what happens if he takes
okay but this should work at all because
f3 is just overloaded if it takes with
the Queen now I've got rogue f3 and some
I cannot believe in for white okay I'm
down to one minute and the screen master
has been completely outplayed but not
sure if i'll make a make the time
yeah what is this extra porn okay
positionally it's also fine but c6 SF is
an issue it's not completely easy some
of course better for black but yeah yeah
it's um this porn on c6 is an issue
yeah I know this looks uh looks terrible
just want to have the time to get the
king over to to cover this I just bishop
situ ah yeah I know I five but you don't
want to play a five here no no no no no
the time the time is smile it's my fate
here again after completely out playing
this is this guy yeah this is easy
evening manish's this is where is stupid
yeah not much I can do i need to resign
him yeah yeah this was difficult to do
in time trouble rook be too maybe if we
keep this actor for characters cannot be
too bad maybe f 6 cm immediately
breaking this up to activate all the
pieces yeah maybe this is better and
it's always some time the shield does
this moves look active but
here it is some is already not that easy
i need to take care about this pawn on
uncie 685 now he's got Bishop a form but
then I can play I can take on deform
stupid yeah okay of course I shouldn't
lose at all and since it's a draw
however I want it but it's um it's not
easy to win with less time yeah middle
given game was quite nice I think with
some interesting ideas yeah okay next
game last one foot